we got a series that's called our more a
more perfect union I know it very well
believe it or not uh and it aims to show
that what unites us is far greater than
what divides us for a child it's
important to have someone to look up to
but finding a mentor who fully
understands can be hard especially when
you have a disability our Elaine quijano
went to Farmingdale New Jersey to meet a
little girl who found just the right
person for her someone who also found a
role model in her
okay
like other five-year-olds Colby gerbero
spends a lot of time in a world of
Make-Believe here you go thank you so
much but her reality has differed since
birth Colby was born 17 weeks premature
at one pound two ounces she's faced a
host of health challenges since
including the muscular disorder cerebral
palsy or CP CP is where you have like CP
and and you use like a walker a cane and
a wheelchair these days Colby is
realizing that others sometimes see her
differently she said Mommy I don't like
when people stare at me Mom I don't like
it I want them to stop I want Colby to
know that she can pick up the phone and
call me for whatever reason Steph roach
was also born with CP she and Colby's
mom Amanda met through social media
where roach a former CrossFit trainer
and book author posts about her life and
defying expectations when I saw Colby
and then I saw the way that Amanda was
guiding Colby through life it was just
like we were meant to to be friends
until now it's been a long distance
friendship the derberos in New Jersey
and roach in Arizona ready come on out
but one January morning who is it
they had their first meeting guess what
I guess what I got I got the same thing
in you
they were immediately comfortable with
each other can I pick you up
you're the best stuff I can't believe
like you're here
I love you Colby realizes that people
are starting to look at her and see her
maybe a little bit differently so we've
had some big conversations about how
that might make her feel and yeah I I
know all about how I feel now is it okay
to tell somebody that you don't like it
yeah we have to be nice about it yeah
but you can still tell somebody that I
don't really like how you stare at me
like that if you have questions I can
answer them for you right yeah if people
have questions they can ask you
after Colby went to play roach
remembered her own childhood I wanted to
be as quote normal as possible but it
really wasn't until I turned probably 20
22 where I really started to own who I
was with self-acceptance came new
chapters a growing circle of friends
success and fitness competitions and
Love Is it true you met Tyler on Tinder
it is very true and I remember telling
him you know hope this doesn't bother
you but I have CP and he said well I'm
pigeon toed so I hope that doesn't
bother you just months into their
relationship her life changed again
during a doctor's visit in 2016. these
lumps were all throughout my body and a
couple weeks later I was diagnosed with
Hodgkin's lymphoma stage 3B it took 12
rounds of chemotherapy before doctors
said her scans were clear Steph and Ty
have since married and faced the out
outside world together we've been in a
grocery store and a man has literally
come up to him and shaken his hand and
said like so good of you to be with her
and like why isn't he lucky to also be
with me she can't stand but she's a
wheelchair for me yeah what would your
hope for Colby be gosh I mean so many
things you know as a mom you just have
all the Hope in the world you know I
used to think that because she had CP
she would be an artist because she
couldn't be an athlete and now I know
that the world is her oyster My Hope Is
that she's exactly who she wants to be
and stuff I hope Colby just finds her
real voice she's capable of doing
anything I just hope that it's part of
her and that she's proud of it because
if I could go back to that five-year-old
girl I would doubt
if if I could go back to my
five-year-old self I would tell her to
be proud of herself
for CBS mornings I'm Elaine quijano in
Farmingdale New Jersey
I think Colby will find her real voice
as Steph founds hers that's a beautiful
piece there Elaine thank you very much
we'll be right back